Our World leader.
Today marks one week
since Russia dusted off its Cold
War playbook and detained
American journalist
Evan Jurkovec
and accused him falsely of espionage.
It's a charge
that is, by all accounts, completely
make believe.
A week later,
the Wall Street
Journal reporter
has yet to even get consular access
or meet with American officials.
Secretary of State
Antony Blinken today said this.
In my own mind, there's no doubt
that he's being wrongfully detained
by Russia,
which is exactly what I said
to Foreign Minister Lavrov
when I spoke to him
over the weekend and insisted
that Evan be released immediately.
Joining us now, retired
journalist Nicholas Daniloff.
He was Moscow bureau chief for U.S.
News and World Report in 1986
when he was falsely arrested
and wrongfully detained
in a KGB prison
for 13 days, falsely
accused of being a spy.
Thanks so much for joining us.
Secretary Blinken says the U.S.
is still preparing
to officially declare
this a wrongful detention,
which would trigger new U.S.
government resources to work toward
his release. It's been a week.
Is the Biden administration working
quickly enough here?
Well, the fact that
Biden's name
has been attached to all of this
strikes me as important
and that the secretary of state
is also involved.
So something is going on.
When the Russians falsely
accused you of being a spy,
did they even bother to try to come up
with any sort of junk evidence
to use against you?
Or did
they just make the claim and lock you up?
They made the claim and locked me up.
You were detained
just days after an employee
of the Soviet
Union's mission to the United Nations
had been arrested in New York.
And both you
and that employee were released
after two weeks
of diplomatic negotiations.
Why do you think Russia,
for the first time
since the Cold War, is now detaining
this, detaining this American journalist,
accusing him of espionage?
Do you think it's the same basic idea?
A Russian spy was arrested.
Therefore,
they took this American journalist
and they just want to do a swap, as
seemed to be the case with you,
that that may well be the case.
I think that
bureaucracy is, you know, remain in place
and they are often guided
by the practice of the past.
So if this seems like
a throwback to the past,
it probably is Gursky,
which is being detained
in the same center
where they detained you
in 1986, a place
that has a long, intimidating history
that dates back to Stalin's purges.
If ever everyone could hear you
right now.
What would be your message
or advice to him as he sits essentially
in the same place you sat?
Well, when I was in that prison,
the one thing that I did not have
any access
to was information from the outside side.
I got information
from visits from my wife.
And so I think
one of the things that he could do
is demand
to be informed about what's going on
in the outside world.
And they probably won't comply with that.
But you make the demand anyway.
Do you
think there's anything
to the fact that both you and Evan
are of Russian descent,
that that might be behind
why they did this?
I would think that
that is not much of a connection.
In my case,
the Russian connection was helpful
in that
I could get on
with the people surrounding me.
I could speak with them in Russian,
and that created a somewhat
more friendly atmosphere
within the prison.
You were released, thankfully,
after 13 days of detention.
This was while
Mikhail Gorbachev was president
of the Soviet Union.
Given that we're dealing with Vladimir
Putin here,
who seems a much more
nefarious individual
than Mikhail Gorbachev, perhaps.
Are you worried at all
the girls Djokovic's story
will not end as quickly
or as smoothly as yours did?
It may not.
Because for the very reason that
that you mentioned.
All right, Nick Daniloff, it's
been an honor talking to you, sir.
Thank you so much.
Really appreciate it.
Well, it's a pleasant
being on your program.
Thank you, sir. Have a good day.